michel serres est ce que c'est le
dossier des malheurs de la terre et là
on en a vu quelques exemples et il ya
beaucoup d'autres livres d'ailleurs qui
parle souvent des mêmes problèmes et
puis parfois d'autres c'est ce dossier
des malheurs de la terre qui vous a
amené à écrire le contrat naturel
pas tout à fait puisque chacun a raconté
l'odyssée qui l'a amené à écrire ce
livre je voudrais raconte ya aussi la
mienne
il ya une dizaine d'années de cela au
moment de la réunion du sol des sommets
des pays industrialisés soul influence
du premier ministre japonais
les pays industrialisés ont voulu faire
des réunions scientifiques
à l'époque vous souvenez où il y avait
des problèmes avec les manipulations
génétiques l'éthique et la biologie etc
et donc il y a eu plusieurs réunions à
tokyo à berlin à bari de chaque pays
industrialisés a envoyé trois personnes
un scientifique un médecin par exemple
est un philosophe par exemple je crois
que le canada avait envoyé un pasteur
protestant la france avait envoyé un
philosophe
alors dans ces réunions là il était
question précisément des problèmes qui
comme aujourd'hui ont été évoqués mais
au lieu que ce soit des problèmes
d'environnement s'était plutôt des
problèmes de santé de biologie de
manipulations génétiques ainsi de suite
et on s'est trouvé très rapidement dans
ces réunions nous étions 21 dans la même
situation que ce soir savoir qu'il y
avait des savants et lorsque les savants
faisait leur exposer tout le monde était
d'accord parce qu'effectivement c'était
des faits des théories des expériences
une suite il n'y avait pas à discuter
ensuite il y avait des journalistes
aussi qui a mené de l'information comme
vous en avez amené aujourd'hui
et là tout le monde était d'accord et
pendant très longtemps au début dans ces
réunions il ya eu un consensus complet
etc puis à un moment on s'est demandé à
quoi servons-nous en d'autres termes que
faut-il faire
et à ce moment là ça n'a plus marché du
tout parce qu' il n'était plus question
de science parce que les savants disais
ce n'est pas nous qui décidons
les journalistes disaient c'est pas nous
qui décidons non plus mais qui décide
alors toute la question était de savoir
comment se mettre d'accord alors on
pouvait pas se mettre d'accord sur la
politique parce que les politiques
gouverner des pays qui étaient séparés
par la concurrence ou parle par des
guerres ou par des sorties de 2 de
bataille entre choix comme tout à
l'heure ghoga voyez donc
or les problèmes étaient globaux et
chaque politique était seulement locale
alors aussi de tourner vers la morale
c'est-à-dire les tic et là il n'y était
plus possible non plus de se mettre
d'accord parce que la morale pratiquée
par un bouddhiste n'était plus du tout
la même que la morale pratiquer parole
d'américain protestants et donc il n'y
avait plus du tout d'accord et au bout
de trois réunions on avait fait le tour
du monde mais aussi plusieurs fois
eh bien ces réunions n'ont plus du tout
d'intérêt et c'est à partir de l'échec
de ces réunions que je suis mis à je me
suis mis à réfléchir sur cette question
et ma première ma première idée a été et
je crois que quelqu'un nous manque ici
je vais vous dire lequel
ma première réaction a été de dire au
fond les seules personnes qui sont
habitués à mettre d'accord des gens qui
ne sont pas d'accord
ce sont en général les juristes et donc
j'ai pensé au droit est ici non parce
que il y à du droit de l'environnement
il ya des livres qui ont été écrits
récemment sur les droits de
l'environnement
il ya eu un livre de martin vraiment
gouyou par exemple qui est un très très
bon livre sur la question
alors je me suis mis à penser à la
question du droit et je me suis
transformé un étudiant en droit j'ai
étudié du droit j'ai fait du droit et je
suis tombé sur les théories du contrat
et ainsi de suite
mais avant de me dire avant d'arriver à
des conclusions de ce genre je me suis
aperçu que quand j'ai fréquenté les
milieux du droit quand j'ai travaillé
sur la philosophie du droit que les
milieux juridiques actuellement sont en
conflit est en conflit ouvert avec le
milieu scientifique et pourquoi b pour
une raison très simple c'est que la
science a un projet à plusieurs projets
les savants ont des programmes et il
désire être
ibra complètement libre de de leurs
projets de leurs programmes et de leurs
objets et au contraire les juristes ont
tendance à mettre des obstacles des
barrières des limitations au projet donc
entre la communauté scientifique et la
communauté juridique
il y à des conflits de plus en plus
violents les nouvelles que vous avez
voulu le faire le pont entre ces deux
communautés
pas encore tout à fait mon cher bernard
pivot parce que à en regardant ces
conflits je me suis aperçu en étudiant
l'histoire de ces conflits que ces
conflits avaient eu lieu pendant toute
l'histoire est que depuis l'origine chez
les grecs
le procès galilée est un état du conflit
entre un certain droit c'était le droit
canon et la recherche scientifique mais
ce procès galilée n'est pas une
exception
je crois qu'il y a actuellement à paris
une pièce de théâtre sur le procès gagné
et on monte en épingle ce procès ne met
pas du tout à l'époque des great par
exemple on peut on peut trouver autant
de procès qu'on veut sur les géomètres
sur les climatologues sur les physiciens
qui avait des conflits ouverts avec la
politique de leur tang le droit de leur
temps et ainsi de suite
par conséquent il ya une sorte de
d'histoire violente des rapports entre
la communauté juridique et la communauté
scientifique et donc tous là toute la
question n'a pas été de dire
seul le droit peut résoudre la question
mais seul le rapport entre le droit et
la science et ça a été au fond le début
le début de mon livre c'est à dire
comment essayer de trouver un équilibre
entre quoi entre la science et le droit
je les dis mais entre la raison
scientifique qui est dynamique il ya un
projet et la raison juridique qui est
équilibré qui est une sorte de prudence
de sagesse qui m'a frappée d'un motif
c'est que vous parlez de la terre en
philosophe je parlais en juriste mais
vous parler d'elle parfois presque
comment dirais-je presqu'en chrétiens
comme si c'était votre prochain ah oui
en effet alors il faut avancer j'ai
parlé de morale puis j'ai parlé de
politique et ensuite j'ai parlé de droit
et puis ensuite des rapports entre la
science et le droit et à un moment un
effet je parle de religion
vous allez remarquer je parle de
religion et ce que j'ai observé
d'ailleurs dans les trois livres que
j'ai lus
c'est que à certains moments la terre
chez eux chez vous aussi bien les
scientifiques les journalistes ou les
professeur de botanique est appelé par
son nom propre il vous l'appelez souvent
gaillard kayak hommes si elles étaient
personnalisés comme si vous aviez
rapport à quelqu'un et ça ça a un nom en
philosophie ça s'appelle le panthéisme
c'est à dire lorsque on considère la
terre de magog l'objet mais comme une
personne comme on l'appelle gaia et
voilà le mot de religion est à ce
moment-là lancée et un des bénéfices de
mon livre je crois c'est de n'avoir pas
fait de religion mais d'avoir interrogé
le mot de religion
vous aimez les mots puisque vous faites
des dictées et le mot religion est moins
intéressant avant même qu'on regarde le
contenu qu'on peut donner par croyance
ou non croyance à la religion ce mot est
composé d'un préfixe heureux et et d'une
racine qui veut dire lié qui veut dire
relier des choses comme ça et si on
enlève le préfixe et si on veut ni et la
religion si en général quand on dit on y
la religion on s'appelle acté ou
mécréants etc
mais non regardez le mot en regardant le
mot devant le préfixe on va mettre ni y
est à dire négation et ça donne le beau
mot français de négligence et tout mon
livre mais dit un peu sur la notion de
négligence savoir que l' inverse de la
religion c'est pas l'athéisme c'est pas
là mais connaître mais créé en mai mais
c'est être négligents je crois que nous
sommes négligent et c'est le mot de
négligence qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup
francs
alors il faudrait dire qu'est ce que
vous appelez le contrôle est naturelle
mais alors revenir ses tous les we re
quelques phrases revenons maintenant à
la théorie du droit dont je suis parti
parce que pour vous mettre d'accord j'ai
senti à un certainement qui avait des
désaccords entre ceux qui sont vraiment
militants écologistes et d'autre part
les savants qui sont plus pauvres a vu
que oui il ya eu en détention je crois
réellement que le droit est souvent une
réduction des tensions
pourquoi parce que tout simplement le
droit c'est le plus souvent une pratique
des contrats alors qu'est-ce qu'on
comptera c'est un pacte qu'on peut
passer entre deux partenaires qui ont
des intérêts divergents qui ont des
intérêts opposés même et les théoriciens
du compte du contrat social ont voulu
essayer d'expliquer pourquoi nous sommes
ensemble pourquoi il ya des sociétés
humaines pourquoi il ya des familles des
villages des villes etc
ils ont imaginé de façon assez
raisonnable d'ailleurs une sorte de
d'hypothèses ou de mythes qui
consisterait à dire que nos ancêtres
dans une sorte de dans une sorte de de
passer aussi ancien que celui de notre
ami aurait signé entre une sorte de
pacte qui aurait consisté à se mettre
d'accord sur le fait qu'on vivrait
désormais ensemble parce que vraiment
vivre séparés a mené à la pauvreté aux
guerres et à une sorte de série de
catastrophes est donc au-delà dans la
théorie en question une bonne théorie
contrat social bon je crois que cette
théorie du contrat social est
intéressante mais qu' elle ne s'occupe
que des relations que nous entretenons
entre nous et je reviens là au tableau
de goya tout à l'heure en parlant du
tableau de goya
on voit bien que les deux les deux les
deux personnes qui sont dans la bataille
sont passionnés par leur relation et
cette relation est tellement passionné
que nous les spectateurs extérieurs au
tableau nous sommes également passionné
par cette relation et nous sommes nous
vivons comme si nous ne pensions qu aux
relations que nous entretenons entre
nous c'est à dire nous vivons comme des
animaux politiques et
nous ne pensons jamais au monde dans
lequel nous entretenons des relations
alors j'ai imaginé que l'ère du contrat
social était disons pas terminé mais
quel club mais qu'elle devait maintenant
suffisante qu'elle était insuffisante
par exemple par exemple je donne
l'exemple des de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme qui est issu comme on
le sait du droit naturel qui a raison de
dire que tous les hommes sont sujets de
droit que nous sommes égaux en droits
mais cette déclaration des droits de
l'homme ne dit rien sur le monde elle ne
dit rien on ne dit rien de la cheminée
la politique ne dit rien du monde ça
veut dire qu'il faut changer tout notre
culture oui oui alors c'est bon essayons
de faire voyons d'introduire la formule
1 par lequel c'est de ça que vous même
monsieur pivot vous après de la fin de
l'histoire
non pas du tout c'est à l'avant on a
l'impression que c'est le début de notre
esprit notre histoire je le crois
profondément parce que dès le moment où
il y à cette difficulté entre le droit
et la science c'est à dire entre la
raison dynamique et la raison disons
équilibré ou sage qui est représentée
par mme anthouard que les scientifiques
ne sont pas sages ils sont non et non
entre le rationnel et le raisonnable
ce que j'ai dit vous avez des solutions
rationnelles même avait peut-être pas
toujours des relais nous nous nous
sommes obligés de faire l'addition
tu vas philosophie le mot sophie veut
dire à la fois ton rationnel et man
raisonnable tu vois essayez-le explique
denis alors ma solution car elle est une
et je la souhaite ardemment sait puisque
vous parlez de nouveau d'une nouvelle
ère où d'un nouveau elle est dans
l'éducation c'est à dire que séné
ducation là la solution à tous les
problèmes dont vous parlez c'est
l'éducation l'éducation du de la
jeunesse l'éducation du jeune enfant
lorsque vous parlez le problème
démographique il est bien évident par
exemple que l'ère de l'individualisme
est achevée on ne peut pas jeter de sa
n'importe où on ne peut pas je me
promenais brunch c'est tous les
comportements qui sont tous les
comportements devaient être changées or
les adultes changent rarement de
comportement
les vieillards changent rarement deux
donc c'est plutôt non pas du tout non
toutes les utopies commence à rentrer
dans l'histoire dès le moment où on les
fait rentrer dans l'enseignement les
gaules est pas convaincu j'ai peur s'il
voulait que le temps nécessaire pour
réaliser cet objectif évidemment très
jolie table la terre soit trop court et
non pas du tout tu parles de danger à 50
ans et l'enseignement et à 20 ans je
pense que la crise dont je parlais nous
parlons la fin c'est la crise
démographique ce robe dont c'est à dire
le monde de plein on ne peut pas agir
dans un monde plein comme on avait
l'habitude d'agir heureusement sa quasi
vides et et jeudi très souvent dans le
livre que si par hasard bernard pivot
vous m'interrogez au moins au mois de
janvier 2000
sur quel est l'événement le plus
important du xxème siècle ne va pas et
je répondrai et bien l'événement le plus
important de xxème siècle c'est la
disparition de l'agriculture en tant
qu'activité pilote de lui-même c'est au
début du siècle la gestion et le marin
oui ma faim mavericks dans le rapport à
la terre c'est ça c'est à dire au début
du siècle nous étions en selon les pays
entre 60 et 80 % d'agriculteurs et dans
la littérature et dans la culture un
livre de flaubert c'est de l'agriculture
en livre de maupassant c'est encore de
l'agriculture et maintenant c'est
terminé
d'ailleurs nous n'avons plus ce
rapport-là au sol nous sommes une autre
humanité et nous nous conduisons comme
si les conditions de vie étaient les
mêmes qu'au début du siècle ce n'est pas
vrai il faut qu'à transformer
complètement notre conduite et
transformer la conduite ce n'est pas un
problème ni de poubelles ni de sciences
est un problème d'éducation et je crois
très profondément que dans notre
civilisation est le pire et c'est ça le
constat le plus difficile c'est que
l'éducation est justement le plus grand
désastre des pays des pays développés
parce que si l'on prend tous les
exemples que l'on a pu voir regarder par
exemple île de pâques qui est celle
d'opel te parle dans son jean et bien
la disparition de cette civilisation
s'est fait absolument à toute vitesse
vous avez vous eu l'occasion de dater
très c'est très amusant une par une les
graines des derniers pamiers qu'il y
avait bien l tat à 10 ans prévue dans
près de là du moment où laisser toutes
les statues sont tombés c'est à dire les
les mac c'est là c'est la fin du végétal
qui entraîne et très vite la fin de
l'homme ces 25 20 en moins de
vingt-quatre voyez la catastrophe
reviens vite vous voyez c'est sa
maîtresse et sa population
je crois profondément que c'est pourquoi
j'ai terminé mon livre sur une sorte de
parabole ou de récits vers un mois jeudi
le problème c'est l'éducation
eh bien j'ai essayé d'éduquer les gens
en finissant mon livre par par une sorte
de par une sorte de légende doyer commun
et je crois que lorsque vous dites ça il
faut alors aller au bout du raisonnement
et dire que le projet de société ça
devrait être
les enfants et or c'est pas ça fait
moins jeunes aux essais les objets
techniques c'est des jouets cd gadget
c'est tout ce qu'on nous vend et de ce
qu'on promet la télévision définition
etc
mais c'est pas les enfants je crois que
le grand projet l'euroligue rérolle du
philosophe ans et de ses deux chats
auger c'est de changer les mentalités
oui on ne peut agir aussi rigoureux que
soit la démonstration du savant aussi
exact soit l'ensemble des faits que vous
apportez en chemin on ne changera rien à
l'histoire si on ne change pas les
conduites et les mentalités et ça c'est
le travail du philosophe je crois enfin
le travail de l'éducateur les du capteur
d'ailleurs chez vous autant que nous que
nous nous professeurs et vous homme de
télévision
oui il ya toute une métaphore sur la
corde sur la corde d'acord du marin la
corde aussi du paysan oui je suis à caen
du paysan siècle à 6000 évidemment au
contrat c'est le contrat doit terminer
simplement là dessus c'est sur l'océan
parce que je n'oublie pas que vous êtes
un ancien officier de marine super c est
ce que j'ai remarqué dans au lycée quand
même l'océan et régénérateur c'est lui
qui luttent contre le
carbonique il a une idée formidable
l'océan il a une capacité de lutter
contre la pollution qu'il subit très
extraordinaire
hélas pas s'étonner qui parce que la
séance est aussi un ensemble d'êtres
vivants qui fabrique des antibiotiques
en masse est qui et qui détruisent les
pollutions beaucoup plus efficacement
effectivement que souvent les sommets où
j'avais et l'océan le volume et la
surface pour lui il ya quand même
beaucoup plus de surface océanique
chérif lui dire il peut transporter
ailleurs les hauts risques c'est qu'un
jour nous le rende parce que le saison
il fonctionne à son rythme propre nous
sommes en train de vouloir aller
beaucoup de pression il sera très bien
se débrouiller de glace carbonique que
l'on en parlait il ya très longtemps que
les philosophes disent que que n'est que
les hommes sont nés de l'eau sont des
delà de la mer et ont fait cette
analogie entre la mer la mer
[Musique]